c'est tout le monde les gaz c'est
squeeze et tasha nous raconte ça fait un
peu peiné dire salut tout le monde les
gags enfin bref
alors aujourd'hui je fais ce que tu
commentaires et je me force un peu à le
faire je dois vous l'avouer je vais
tourner l'écran puisque je suis pas bien
en face de l'écran
je me force un peu à le faire parce que
bon vous savez que je pars en vacances
le 4 est en fait je reviens le vin je
reviens pas le 24 mai le vin enfin mon
[ __ ] faut aller au bordel alors oui
donc j'ai décidé tu me fortress 2 parce
que paraît-il que c'est un jeu
complètement dingue
j'avais déjà joué mais je n'avais pas
trouvé ça génial
bon je sais pas peut-être que peut-être
que faut il jouer entre amis je ne sais
pas pour bien se marrer bon c'est ce qui
m'avait été conseillé comme quoi qu'il
en soit qu'est ce que je suis en rouge
et vert bleu passé là-bas en string et
en aval pour suivre et un chauffeur de
la ligne berne alors attendez si bien de
chasser les faits à blue de flou quand
on tourne comme ça si vous regardez bien
ces mêmes effets qu'on rajoute dans les
fringues movie enfin bref c'est pas mal
j'aime bien déjà sagem what the fuck
[ __ ] mais rarement des gens c'est les
gros porc est pris à des classes de 2de
gros la fin bref je sûr si james bond
jouage où il prendrait la classe espion
a comme c'était naze alors attendez bon
alors je vais essayer de me concentrer
un peu d'enjeu de celui-là je ne
comprends pas trop giacomo lui il arrive
à courir comme ça comme un lapin alors
que moi je marche comme comme grosse
daube
alors attendez voyons voir je me cachais
j attends que les ennemis arrivent
ah d'accord c'est gravé comme une merde
bon je vois je réponds que j'ai fait ça
non je n'ai pas pété merci je sais très
bien que tu as toujours des petits
malins pour dire dans les commentaires à
mes blagues aux aux campeurs aux
campeurs les crèmes mais c'est une
blague mais non mais non mais attendez
mais siams ya même des campeurs dans un
jeu comme ça non mais franchement qu'est
ce que vous voulez faire mais sans rire
quoi [ __ ] est d'ailleurs en parlant de
ça récemment j'ai mes [ __ ] reprendre
à fermer aux îles sont chiantes
récemment j'ai craqué mon slip comme
jamais sur une partie j'ai cru que
j'avais cassé mon bureau alors je
m'explique sur pc il a constamment une
connexion de merde bon ça c'est pas
nouveau à ces mêmes bruxelles ce en
passant ça c'est ça c'est pas nouveau
vous savez bien que sur pc on a toujours
une connexion de merde ce modern warfare
2 et acheter vu tu te prends pour qui
mel août façon je m'en fous lui il
mourra jamais bon ok je vais faire un
coup à l'est j'ai ce passé les gros à
les aimer bros enfin bref je dis que
j'avais donc la connexion de merde et en
plus j'avais une communauté en face de
moi s et mais [ __ ] mais c'était
franchement c'est que si c'est à dire
qu'ils jouent et une pile de cette
mecque
elle jouit tous à l'ump tous aller mais
l'ua mais [ __ ] mais c'est un mec dans
matrix là où c'est le méchant avec sa
tête de [ __ ]
enfin bref je disais ultime de cette
mecque alors on avait trois rohner ceux
qui courent point g commando a été
charcuté alors oui c'est un strictement
à rien mais la faire [ __ ]
j'étais en train de parler enfin bref
ensuite y'a quoi d'ottawa où il y avait
les ump alors
[Musique]
alors ils sont super lourd et pour finir
les youtube je tourne enfin je te vois
une chose alors que la probable arrivée
à 50 mètres de toi [ __ ] mais
franchement j'en pouvais plus il y avait
deux autres mais qui n'étaient pas dans
leur team et que jouer à je ne sais pas
quoi je ne sais même pas à quoi il joue
et sûrement un intervention fut loto
enfin bref du foutage de gueule je n'en
pouvais plus et à un moment j'ai fait ça
et j'en pouvais plus est en train de
craquer mon slip vous pouvez demander à
mes yeux c'est forlan jay z c'est ci a
ouvert cette vidéo ben vous composez
demande et il vous répondra ses regards
la vidéo vous verrez que c'était assez
impressionnante de craquer à ce point là
bon au niveau du gameplay c'est à
sachiez j'essaie de faire un truc
potable et pour les vacances je voulais
aussi vous dire que je vais pas c'est à
dire qui a bee doo wop bas la vidéo et
non mes recherches mais [ __ ] il ne
faudrait pas se passe dans ce jeu pourri
là non je rigole je ne sais pas je
brille c'est juste que je ne sais pas y
jouer
tiens voilà mon ami c'est quelqu'un
d'autre qui me le borgne où toi je t'ai
vu là haut où je dis tu t'es tu es dans
ta face dans sa phase deux cas on va
regarder les deux ont déjà des frites 10
et ses bienfaits et [ __ ] alors en tout
cas j'ai vu un
un bleu c'est un bleu ça ou au nom
geruge avait fait un double cheese fait
chier bref fait chier pour les vacances
j'ai donc décidé de ne pas faire la
technique du a dû parce qu'en fait nzz
et là est encore là par exemple moi je
parle car il sera là jusqu'au 10
donc de toutes façons ne pourrait plus
adéquat deux vidéos pire que je vais me
forcer à faire bon ça sert à rien donc
là je vais faire une vidéo par jour
jusqu'au 4 août enfin je vais essayer en
tout cas je vais essayer joue première
mais pas la preuve je me force à faire
cette petite vidéo donc c'est quand même
une preuve d'amour entre vous et moi car
je vais me l'offrir
enfin bref et puis bah et ben voila en
gros deux vidéos par georges que 4 août
et puis ensuite tu vous faudra attendre
presque trois semaines puisque je
reviens que le vent en fin de semaine
deux semaines et 2 jours mais [ __ ]
mais c'est par bout quoi bon allez je
vais suivre les flèches quand votre iso
aux besoins de vue
c'est dommage le pop qui elle-même
boulet je suis alors voyez au show de
gad et ça c'est quoi c'est une pelle tu
as koupèla je sais tu es un mec à la
paix non à temps sans rien lâcher sinon
tu fais avec ça tiens tiens et alors me
le vole et voilà alors je lui
suite à un trop bon je lai aulas oh
[ __ ] n'a pas vu ma vue super con je
faisais mais j'imagine et je le réécoute
stopper tous là attendant on va essayer
de faire à regarder quand la balle est
allée boom dans ta face de deux pelles à
houla hop là ou là là là là là là on ne
peut pas doubler ce sujet dans ce jeu
sebaâ naker of realtors c'est d'apporter
quoi ce jeu en tout cas ça doit être
bien marrant tout seul là bon je me
marre parce que c'est comme si vous
étiez avec moi mais en tout cas ça doit
être bien marrant dit jouer avec des
potes c'est vrai je vous la corde mais
bon pourtant ça me tente pas trop mais
bon pourquoi bram boo rabat why not j'ai
envie de vous dire alors aussi j'ai eu
des superbe enceinte je peux pas vous le
montrer je pense je suis raide vidéos
regardées a ressemble à ça je sais pas
si vous pouvez bien voir là comme ça bon
bref en tout cas là vous ne voyez pas
question de base mais vous savez quoi on
va faire une vidéo complètement inutile
demain ou mardi
you're a person chez moi donc je vais
tester le volume à fond du fond du fond
et je peux vous dire que le volume en
mode fond du fond de la faune du fond de
la fondue à la fondue savoyarde
ok c'était mal je pense que ça pourra
rendre un truc aura donc on testera
ensemble voilà bon là je ferai le coup
en train de danser comme un con comme ça
enfin bref voilà comment dit jo comme
vous m'avez déjà vue dans plusieurs
vidéos danser comme un trésor
enfin bref où je t'ai vu tu dois vivre
ou la voilà mon copain gérer essentielle
car à mon avis au maine
non mais oh je t'ai vu j'ai relu séances
pai aux eaux
c'est quoi as tu ne m'auras pas non non
non plus oh oui merci vas-y toi tu as un
bon père bon [ __ ] c'est n'importe quoi
c'est juste un peu un truc de bord
regarder le lui dire a vu ni à lula bord
des tirs de roquettes ça soit fermé
alors attendez attention en mode gros
porc au je suis un peu dans la base des
bleus
ah oui si le médecin ils ont aidé à
commettre monde chuté enfin bref on en
dénombre de mer plutôt allez allez mon
ami et moi j'en fait de la non à la
banque est bien joué mais bravo à toi et
ton pistolet laser tumeur injectée du
laser enfin bref ah oui aussi je voulais
vous raconter l'histoire est là en fin
de saison bio et ou avec des amis
et puis là on arrive mange 21 on est
deux avoir un pistolet laser ce qui est
pas un pistolet laser il avait un le
truc ça fait plus tout le monde meurt
tous les genres et tous les angles ils
feront enfin bref on était trop bien
parti en ce moment on avait chacun
harper km h 41 et comme par hasard on
arrive mange 21 au 22 chez q qu'est ce
que ça fait connexion interrompue et
voilà j'étais quitter la partie du coup
ils ont arrêté et on était dégoûté on
était partis on avait toutes nos armes
améliorées on avait des millions de
points et tout enfin bref sans rien
j'avais un peu le sommet pourquoi il est
tout rouge qu'il a il excite et elle est
excitée - lance-roquettes je sais pas il
est lavé une belle fille enfin bref
quoiqu'il en soit je vais vous laisser
les amis je vous dis à très bientôt pour
un nouveau commentaire est demain
enfreint rang de commentaires et vous
verrez ce que c'est et la non à notre
super mamie qui lancent des frites
c'est vraiment génial entre bon bref en
tout cas je vous dis à bientôt
demain on se retrouve pour le rendent
aux commentaires et après demain le
premier top-5 de la connerie et je vous
dit ciao tout mon bail